[LAUGHING]
>> Laura: IT’S FRIDAY, WHICH
MEANS IT’S TIME FOR -- OH,
PROTESTERS GET CREATIVE OUTSIDE
MITCH McCONNELL’S HOUSE AND
SEXUAL POLITICS ARE TAKING OVER
BOARD ROOMS AND CLASSROOMS.
FOR THE DETAILS, WE’RE JOINED BY
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, COMEDIAN DURING
BREAKS, AND AUTHOR OF "THE WILL
WILDER SERIES."
TELL ME ABOUT THE EARLY MORNING
PROTESTS OUTSIDE OF McCONNELL’S
CONDO.
>> IT’S 7:30 IN THE MORNING AND
YOU ARE AWAKENED BY A PROTEST
COMING UP THE BLOCK.
ELAINE, WHAT IS THAT OUT THERE.
THEN HE SAW THIS.
[CHANTING]
>> CHUG, CHUG, CHUG, CHUG!
I LIKE BEER!
I LIKE BORE!
-- I LIKE BEER!
>> Laura: THEY WERE WALKING UP
THE BLOCK SAYING "I LIKE BEER,"
"CHUG, CHUG, CHUG".
>> THIS IS LIKE PIRATES OF THE
CANADIAN, JOINED BY THE DUNKEN
PROTESTERS.
THEY HAVE PABST RED RIBBON --
>> Laura: RED?
IT’S BLUE.
>> I DON’T TOUCH THE STUFF
STUFF.
AND THEY HAVE THE RED SOLO CUPS.
BRETT KAVANAUGH AT HIS HEARING
DID MENTION THIS.
>> WE DRANK BEER, MY FRIENDS AND
I, BOYS AND GIRLS, YES, WE DRANK
BEER.
I LIKE BEER.
STILL LIKE BEER.
WE DRANK BEER.
WE LIKE BEER.
>> MY QUESTION, I DON’T KNOW
WHAT THE PROTEST IS ABOUT.
IF YOU DON’T LIKE THE GUY WHY
ARE YOU MIMICKING HIS WORDS.
DO YOU SUPPORT HIM OR NOT?
>> Laura: SEEMS LIKE ANY RANDOM
MORNING ON FRAT ROW AT
DARTMOUTH, WHAT WE WERE DOING.
>> DIDN’T LOOK LIKE A PROTEST,
IT WAS COLLECTION OF DISGRUNTLED
MEMBERS.
>> Laura: A ZONING DPROOEF
ANSWER.
>> THIS WAS A CREATIVE PROTEST
COMPARED TO THE BOWELS OF THE
CAPITOL.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZER, GIVING HIS
MARCHERS ORDERS.
BUT I THINK, ARE THEY IN
KINDERGARTEN?
YOU BE THE JUDGE.
>> LET’S GO WATCH THE KROET.
>> LET’S GO WATCH THE VOTE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> I AM GOING TO GO --
>> HI.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE FUN.
>> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, THEY
WERE GOING TO THE WRONG OFFICE.
WEREN’T THEY GOING TO HEIDI
HEITKAMP?
WAIT, ZOMBIE, SHE’S ON OUR SIDE.
OH.
TOTALLY MY BAD.
>> WHY DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CHANT AND ECHO FOR BASIC ORDERS.
>> Laura: WE’RE GOING TO THE
OFFICES.
>> TO THE OFFICES.
THE "ME TOO" MOVEMENT GETTING A
BIG BIRTHDAY PRESENT.
IN CALIFORNIA THE GOVERNOR
REQUIRING PUBLIC CORPORATIONS
TO, IN HIS STATE, TO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE FEMALE DIRECTOR ON
THEIR BOARD.
BY 2021, EVERY BOARD HAS TO HAVE
THREE FEMALE DIRECTORS.
IS THIS CONSTITUTIONAL?
>> Laura: I THINK PACIFIC
ISLANDERS, LATINO AMERICANS, AND
EVERY OTHER GROUP SHOULD SAY,
WHAT ABOUT ME.
>> HOW ABOUT MEN?
I JUST WANT MEN TO BE ON THE ALL
FEMALE BOARDS.
>> Laura: THERE ARE NO ALL
>> LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE
SELFIE SUICIDE.
THE INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES, 259
PEOPLE IN SEVEN YEARS, LOST
THEIR LIVES TAKING THESE RISKY
SELFIE SHOTS.
MOSTLY MEN.
PEOPLE BETWEEN 10 AND 29.
BUT THAT NUMBER IS REALLY LOW.
THEY’RE SAYING IT’S ALMOST 250,
IT’S MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT.
ALL THEY DID WAS LOOK AT
PUBLICLY DECLARED CASES A LOT
THAT WENT UNDECLARED.
PEOPLE ON ROOFTOPS, MONUMENTS,
IN TRAFFIC, AND THEY’RE DYING
TAKING SHOTS.
REAL VANITY.
BEFORE I GO.
>> Laura: UH-OH.
>> JUST TO BRING IT ALL
TOGETHER, LAURA, THE WHOLE
SEGMENT.
WE’LL TAKE SELFIE.
YOU TAKE THAT ONE.
>> Laura: THIS HURTS MY HAND.